october memorial committee is hearing
the thoughts of thousands who took a
survey it focused on what the future
memorial should include the committee
was appointed by the county to gather
public input hector mejia live outside
the clark county government center with
the results hector
there will almost 5200 people most from
the community responded to the survey
which asked them about the artistic
design and education sides of the
memorial the memorial will eventually be
built at the site of the route 91
harvest festival this is the second
survey since march 73 of respondents
felt that education should be a
significant component with support for
the following stories of community
heroism mental health survivor stories
lessons learned by first responders and
the hospitality industry there is also
discussion about whether or not people
should be allowed to leave mementos
focus groups suggested they should be
limited or perhaps not allowed out of
maintenance concerns
minda smith whose sister nisha tonks was
killed in the shooting is part of the
one october memorial committee
i feel like a question like this is very
black and white and it's do mom mementos
do not moment
momentos
and there's not a lot of discussion with
it when someone's answering from a
computer
so i feel like a question like this
almost needs more detail it almost needs
more explanation
when it comes to the artistic side
respondents backed the idea of having
references to country music and a
symbolic representation of the 58
victims killed that night however two
women died a few years after and the
death toll was officially changed to 60
in 2020 by sheriff joe lombardo and this
was just a discussion not an agenda item
for action the next meeting is scheduled
for september 22nd reporting outside the
clark county government center hector
mejia 8 news now all right thanks hector
the vegas strong resiliency center is
also putting out a request for quilts
ahead of one october they hope to
collect 150 quilts by september 17th so
if you'd like to donate we have more
information on eightnewsnow.com